the good part about this topic
is that the types of questions you will
see are very few and repetitive
one category is that of forming numbers
we will be given a few digits and will
be asked to form numbers
for example with these six digits we
could be asked of
how many three-digit numbers we can form
next we might be asked to form anagrams
here we will be given a word a word like
silent
and asked for the number of anagrams we
can form with these six letters
an anagram of a word can be formed by
simply rearranging its letters
an anagram of silent would be listen
another anagram would be e-s-i-t-l-n
what does it mean nothing it's a
meaningless anagram
it won't work in scrabble another
category of problems
would be that of arranging people we
could be asked the number of ways
in which we can seat people on four
chairs or maybe arrange them around a
circular table
so in this session and the next few we
will be looking at the first category
arranging digits to form numbers
let's say we have these five digits with
us
and this is what we're asked read the
question well
how many three-digit numbers can be
formed
let's form three slots here for the
three digits
how many three-digit numbers can we form
using these five digits
and with this question we have been
given two conditions
first it asks us the answer when
repetition is not allowed
let us understand the first condition
repetition
is not allowed look at the number
one one one this is a three digit number
but the digit one is repeated look at
two three two
or five four four the digit two is
repeated here
and the digit 4 is repeated here
by repetition not being allowed they
mean that numbers like these
should not be considered each of the
digits in the slot
should be different so numbers like 1 2
3 3 4 1 or 5 2 4
are allowed as the digits in each case
are different from each other
so let's make three slots for the digits
again
now you can start thinking how many
three-digit numbers can be formed if
repetition
is not allowed before you think of the
three-digit numbers
look at the slots individually let's
look at the first slot or the hundreds
place
in how many ways can you fill the first
slot
it is a simple question you don't need
to know permutations or combinations for
this
in how many ways can you fill the first
slot you can fill it with any of the
five digits right
you can fill it with a one or a two or a
three or a four
or a five these are the five digits
given to us
did you listen carefully i use the word
or one or a two or a three
and so on so five ways and all
we can fill it with any one of these
five digits
okay now listen to the next question
carefully
having filled the slot with one of the
digits in how many ways can we fill the
second slot
easy we have used one of the digits here
it can be any digit doesn't matter but
after having used one four digits remain
so the second slot can be filled in four
ways
if we fill the first slot with one we
have
two three four five as possibilities
here
if we fill the first slot with three we
have
one two four five as the possibilities
for the second slot
now tell me having filled the first and
the second slot
in how many ways can the third slot be
filled
it's simple we have used up two digits
here
only three remain the third slot can be
filled in three ways
we're almost done almost
the first slot can be filled in five
ways the second in
four ways and the third in three ways
so how many three-digit numbers can be
formed if repetition
is not allowed do we add these three
or do we multiply them what are we doing
are we filling in the first slot or the
second slot or the third slot
or are we filling in the first slot and
the second slot
and the third slot it will be and
yes we are filling all three slots and
not just one
and as we have seen in the previous
session is multiplication
so we multiplied these three five times
four
is 20 and 20 times three is 60.
there are 60 ways in which we can form
three digit numbers
without repetition of digits these
include numbers like
one two three three one four two four
five
and so on no repetition
hope this was clear here we started off
with the hundreds place
can we start off with the units place
of course yes we could have if we would
have started off with the units place
we could say that the units place could
be filled in five ways
once the unit's place is filled the
tenths place would be filled with
any of the remaining four digits and
once two digits are utilized
the hundreds place can be filled with
any one of the remaining three digits
three times four times five will also
give us the same answer
sixty ways if you really understood this
then understanding the second stated
condition would be super easy
let's repeat the question on a new page
this time we solve the question keeping
in mind the second condition
given these five digits how many
three-digit numbers can be formed
assuming repetition is allowed
so now we are allowed to consider
numbers like one one one
or three two two and so on so we have
three slots for the three digits
how many three digit numbers can be
formed when repetitions
are allowed i want you to try this
remember repetitions are allowed
so now we are allowed to consider all
numbers which we had
ignored earlier we should have the
possible numbers
greater than 60. try it
ok as we saw earlier let's go slot by
slot
in how many ways can the hundreds place
be filled
it can be filled with any one of the
five digits we have
it can be filled in five ways now in how
many ways can the second slot be filled
think well the second slot can also be
filled in
five ways why it's because
repetitions are allowed if we used up
one digit here
the same one can be used here as well so
no matter what digit is used in the
hundreds place
the tens place can be filled with any
one of the five digits we have been
given
and similarly the third slot can also be
filled with
any one of the five digits five ways
again
if we have one in the hundreds place the
same one can be used in the tens place
and in the units place as well there are
no restrictions
here so as we are filling in the first
and the second
and the third slot we multiply these
three numbers
and get the answer as 125 ways
what does this answer imply relative to
the previous one
let's go back and see the previous
answer
if repetition wasn't allowed there were
60 ways in which we can form
three-digit numbers and if repetition is
allowed
there are 125 ways
why has the number increased it's
obvious
here apart from the no repetition ones
like one two three three one four two
four
five we have allowed numbers like one
one one
two two two four three four and many
more like them to be considered
so i hope both cases are clear
repetition allowed
and not allowed which case do you think
is easier to solve
think it is the repetition allowed case
we don't have to worry about any of the
conditions given
it makes life really easy and you will
realize
why when you watch the further sessions